[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and we're here in
lower Yosemite in California talking
about the mental aspects of training in
Aikido and what those are and we're
talking a little bit right now about the
concept of Kokoro Kokoro means the
interplay between your conscious mind
and your unconscious mind and what that
that interplay is there's a lot of
different words that the Japanese have
that that describe these kinds of
relationships and usually you hear those
they have shin at the end right so
Mushin food oceans on shin sho shin
these are words that are trying to point
at some kind of way of being and I
believe all these words are really kind
of an ability to get at the concept of
coke view and we'll talk about coke cue
later but they're they're kind of ways
that one can balance the mind balance
the interplay between the conscious mind
and the unconscious mind and I think one
of those concepts it's really really
interesting is the concept of mu shin
and move the the kanji for mu is without
void like nothingness and the the idea
of shin of course is Kokoro which is a
balancing or an interplay of the
conscious and unconscious mind so when
you hear motion it's often directly
translated as no mind which i think is
really confusing to Westerners or people
who aren't used to training in esoteric
Japanese things because it sounds like
them you don't have a mind there is no
mind at all or that your mind disappears
or your thoughts disappear and and I
know definitely when I began training in
meditation that I thought the concept of
mushin was that my mind would go
completely blank that there would be no
thoughts in my head and I remember
chastising myself quite a lot for
sitting and thoughts are rising in my
head and then being mad that dr. Rose
you know like oh my god these thoughts
have arisen in my head if I were really
training and I was really
good there be no thoughts in my head and
I can't achieve mu shin and all you know
terrible me and and the problem is not
the thought that arises in your head
it's your attachment to the thought that
arises in your head and and that's
what's not Mushin it's not that the
thought is a problem
it's me chastising myself about the
thought that's a problem my conscious
mind just kicks out thoughts all the
time that's what it does it just fits
its job it's job is to like pick up on
things all the time to go hey what about
this what about this what about this
what about this and in truth probably
more what's happening is my unconscious
mind isn't certain about something and
so it checks in with my conscious mind
that says hey conscious mind check this
out if I allow the conscious mind to go
then I'm attaching to something that's
already done it's already over and and
the idea of motion is that I should be
directly in the moment allowing my
unconscious mind to do what it does and
allowing my conscious mind to do what it
does now as weird as this might sound I
can let my conscious mind do its
conscious mind stuff but I still don't
have to be attached to that and if
you're using this so I can Gio was a run
Dory when you see someone who's having a
really good G OWASA they are doing it
because they have very good moose chin
so their motion is good meaning that
what happens is they're unconscious body
is reacting to the situation the
unconscious mind is reacting to the
situation and they're conscious mind is
just observing and being with it it's
neither congratulating or chastising
right so your conscious mind isn't
watching your body do something and then
saying all good job like good for you
that's good that's so good because that
energy you're putting into
congratulating yourself is taking away
from the moment it's also not chastising
you right like oh you did that wrong oh
you messed up there oh you screwed up
there all of that stuff is also pulling
you out of the moment so when you have
good motion your conscious mind and your
unconscious mind are working beautifully
together and sometimes when we talk
about the concept of Mushin we'll talk
about the concept of Kokoro nomizu which
means like mind like water right and if
you think about water if
if light comes on water it reflects the
light back exactly the way it is
if you pour water into a glass it
becomes the shape of the glass if you
run your hands through water water moves
aside and lets you move your hand
through and so when you're you're
working on your motion you want to have
this this idea of Kokoro nomizu which is
your mind's like water it can flow from
one place to another place and and be
okay wherever it is as opposed to you
making judgments about it and being
critical about it because all that those
problems those judgments you're making
are just pulling you out of the moment
and they're taking more processing power
away from what you need to be doing
which is right in the moment right so in
the moments not the time to analyze
something whether it be good or bad it's
just the time to let it be and if your
unconscious mind needs help
your conscious mind can come in and do
its job it can't assess something you go
oh that's what I should be doing but it
but you shouldn't attach to it in a
judgmental way that has nothing to do
with the moment so I think motion is a
really tricky concept because it doesn't
mean that you're completely your
conscious mind isn't doing its job
because that's what it does the only way
to get your conscious mind to shut
totally office to be dead and so your
conscious mind should be allowed to do
what it does but you don't want to have
judgments and criticisms and
congratulations about what's happening
you just want to let it be so this is
kind of the concept of Mushin and and
how it relates to Aikido training we'll
talk about some more of these in some
some future videos here I'm Chris Ryan
thanks for watching